this week we're talking about data
fusion VPC service controls and cloud
armor I'm Joanna Smith and welcome to
this week in cloud where we serve you
the lowest latency news cloud data
Fusion is now generally available data
fusion is a great tool for seasoned
engineers and movies alike because it
makes it easy to clean transform and
blend data whether you're short on data
engineers or you just like to make their
job a little less mundane this tool is
here to help VPC service controls is a
tool that allows admins to mitigate the
risk of data breaches and now debugging
an understanding denied requests from
the tool gets simpler with unique
identifiers it's one thing to know that
you're defending against breaches but
another to trace your way through the
logs and figure out where the bad actors
are coming from so here's wishing you
quick resolutions to your access issues
google cloud armor helps enterprises
protect both themselves and their users
from DDoS and targeted web attacks and
we're now adding Web Application
Firewall capabilities to expand the
scope of protection as well as custom
rules and geo based access controls and
more these updates are currently in beta
to try them out and let us know what you
think okay
small flex Gartner named Google Cloud a
leader in its 20-19 Magic Quadrant
report for operational database
management systems this is pretty cool
for us to hear but what's actually
really cool is hearing that our users
like us because for our team recognition
like this reinforces that our customers
believe our databases are flexible open
and easy to use and that's our priority
and we do it for y'all
anytime you've got feedback to share
we're happy to hear it if you want to
read more about these announcements or
see a full list check out the link any
thoughts or ideas leave us a comment or
tweet us and we'll see you in the cloud
you